president biden embarrassing himself on
the world stage while trying to show
nato is united against russia
biden in poland today visiting u.s
troops and refugees that comes after the
commander-in-chief directly contradicted
what his own administration has been
saying for weeks about sanctions
deterring russia
let's get something straight you
remember if you covered me from the very
beginning i did not say that in fact the
sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter do you believe the
action today will have an impact on
making russia change of course in
ukraine that's not what i said you
you're playing a game with me
the president believes that sanctions
are intended to deter the purpose of the
sanctions has always been and continues
to be deterrence the purpose of the
sanctions in the first instance is to
try to deter russia from going to war we
do see them as having a deterrent impact
and now biden's causing even more
confusion overseas by telling american
troops in poland that they may soon be
sent off to ukraine
ukrainian people have a lot of backbone
they have a lot of guts and i'm sure
you're observing it and i don't mean
just the military and you're going to
see when you're there and if sometimes
you've been there you're going to see
you're going to see women
young people standing standing in the
middle of the front damn tank
just saying i'm not leaving
i'm holding my ground
the white house quickly coming out to
mop up joe's mess insisting american
troops won't be going to ukraine
all right i'll start with you greg
so we've got this constant back and
forth between the president and the
white house let's talk about sending
troops to ukraine he's talking to the
82nd airborne he is literally over there
in eastern europe and telling them
they'll be there and you'll witness it
he even used that verb as well as see it
i don't know what the hell he was
talking about that is that it's pretty
scary i mean when trump would say
something that was considered rash it
was directionally true that's
directionally insane because it's
running complete 100 miles away from the
truth or at least or maybe that is the
truth and maybe we're being lied to we
don't know when joe talks the world you
feel a kind of a mild embarrassment like
when you go out to dinner with a
relative who's
not quite all there and you hope that
she doesn't snap at the waitress or conk
out in the desert tray uh and but what
you see is what you get it's not like
it's like you always heard about trump
being different behind the scenes he was
like a he was like a presidential mullet
in reverse partying the front but sirius
in the back so he would flatter a leader
but then he'd get to brass tacks
somewhere else but now there's a story
emerging or maybe it's just a theory i
made up because it's friday you know
putin took crimea under obama and
invaded ukraine under joe and why is
that because the administrations are
essentially the same and they have the
same predictable nature so what was what
was that gap in between it was trump why
did putin hold off because trump's brand
is unpredictability how can anybody deny
this putin was like maybe i better not
do it while that guy's around because
who knows what he's going to do he might
bomb my palace so right now he sees
biden as kind of a hood ornament for the
obama administration and knew that he
could pull it off and then he invades
which is a clear violation of
international law causes a lot of
brutality
because well he knew he could
maybe he was being unpredictable yes
yeah well he was certainly unpredictable
as it relates to his claims that uh
sanctions would never deter
russia from going after ukraine jesse
you don't hand biden a hot mic next to a
war zone
the guy is gassed from this trip it's
friday you strap a teleprompter to his
eyeballs and you let it rip this we
can't risk something this crazy and then
the white house comes and mops it up
like he's some
drunk celebrity what my client meant to
say was the exact opposite of what he
did say and it's not just that it's the
deterrence they're on the wrong page
remember when he said you know if they
take a tiny chunk of ukraine maybe we
won't do anything or how about he shares
the intel with the chinese the chinese
just hand it to the kremlin the mig
fiasco the russians and the saudis won't
take his phone calls this is a mess and
to act like it's not a mess is a real
problem right now we don't know if biden
misspoke and he's not planning on that
or he's planning on it and he slipped
now how scary is that and you got to
think the russians are looking at this
six ways from sunday trying to figure
out what's going on here
we don't know what's going on here
either
okay
katie that there's a sound i want you to
take a listen to we'll come to you on
the other side of it
putin has issued russia's energy
resources to coerce
and manipulate its neighbors that's how
he's used it he's used the profits to
drive his war machine
that's why earlier this month i
announced the united states would ban
all imports of russian energy to make it
clear that american people would not be
part of subsidy the united states and
the european union are going to work
together to take concrete measures to
reduce dependence on natural gas
okay now what's interesting about that
katie is that the treasury department
has assured wall street that it can
still trade russian oil and gas through
june 24th right so what does he mean
does he mean anything that he says he's
talking about the ban on imports of
russian gas and oil but the sanctions on
that don't go into place until june
unless and maybe if they even do that
you'll remember that donald trump
president donald trump in 2019 had a
very harsh meeting with the head of nato
talking about this exact thing you are
spending money with russia they're going
to manipulate you and use this as a
weapon they laughed at him and said he's
being too harsh and didn't want the
alliance to maintain its credibility
when really he was saying your
decisions in terms of business and who
you allow to control your energy sector
are going to hold you hostage once
things get hot now that's exactly where
we are
on the communications standpoint
miscommunications lead to
miscalculations which cause wars that's
how wars start and the communication
from this administration has been so
sloppy when it comes to what they say
what they actually mean and bringing up
president obama in
2014 you know in syria
the president there called obama's bluff
when he drew a red line and didn't
follow up with it and russia also called
called his bluff and they went into
syria and they've been there ever since
helping with the civilian annihilation
in that country and now they're doing it
in ukraine knowing that joe biden says a
lot of things that maybe he doesn't mean
or if he's unclear about it president
trump he said what he meant and they
took him seriously that's not the case
in the situation and people who are in
the united states military
stationed in nato countries that
happening right now are very nervous
about a misstatement turning into a
miscalculation in a very volatile
situation you know and jessica biden has
been boasting that he's going to get
europe off of russian oil even though
we're maxed out on our domestic natural
gas production uh and he's not
increasing the supply how is he gonna do
that
i i think that he's going to have to he
did say when he was in pennsylvania that
he wasn't completely anti-fracking i
mean we only had three percent of our
oil coming from russia in the first
place but what he's trying to manage is
you know ten fifteen twenty countries
and how they're going to have a
relationship with russia
let's manage this country and get it
but
this is not just about us unfortunately
we just saw that a saudi refinery got
blown up today and the price of oil
spiked right back up to 113 dollars a
barrel it was down to 96 dollars just a
few days ago there are obviously global
factors that's obviously not related to
what's going on in ukraine with russia
at all and that can happen and that can
slash our supply i understand what you
want me to say is that he's just going
to frack us into oblivion and then we'll
be completely energy independent and
everything will be fine i don't want you
to say anything really say whatever you
want to say well i said that because
well greg at least wanted me to say that
i did yeah
but
i want to say something about the
communications part
of this i don't think that
the 82nd airborne or anyone is confused
about what we're doing about troops
because he misspoke i do think that what
he was saying was by being in this
region you're going to see the strength
of the ukrainians they are streaming
into poland right now right walking
across the the borders we hear about
mothers walking with three pets and five
children picking up kids by the side of
the road i think that's what he was
talking about and it does seem
like everybody is unified here and i
would put it to the table
what would a republican president or
someone besides biden who you think is
more competent be doing any differently
at this point because to my mind all i
see is that your option is that we're
putting troops we're putting boots on
the ground and then we're possibly
heading to a nuclear war or we're
continuing
you give them the s 300 you give it but
that can target war oh so we should
cower in a corner because we're afraid
of we're not just carrying and john
kirby has even said that we're doing
more than we're talking about publicly
which is how you want your government to
operate they're still leveling the
country they're leveling the country but
there are also we hear about that
putin's inner circle is collapsing
around him by the way that's the effect
of sanctions right those are really rich
people who are having their money
sanctioned we hear about there was a
brigade where russian troops killed
their own commander because they didn't
want to fight this war anymore and
that's all very meaningful i'm not i'm
not saying tomorrow this will be over
but i think it's really the things we
wanted you to say yes
i already said fracking into oblivion
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else